what we learned from the yura campaign I
think the most significant factor was
that he is the accident-prone leader
somebody who's on the campaign trail and
the story is going to be what goes wrong
rather than what he wants it to be he is
the opposite devorah's Johnson Boris
Johnson has accidents and there are a
great victory I remember when he was
stuck in that zip wire and the Olympics
and he's the only politician I think in
the world you could turn that into a
triumph but that's Boris for you and him
you know the man's got the opposite
effect he could do something really
boring like it's his lunch and that can
be seen as a disaster and then you can
blame the wicked media to an extent with
some politicians have a neck for
disasters he's got one and Boris
Johnson's got a knack for triumphs well
his brother had this as well and he was
caught with a banana a Labour conference
several years ago wasn't he is about I
think it's a case of Miliband not being
entirely comfortable in his own skin
Boris is completely his own man which is
why he gets away with being posh in a
way that David Cameron doesn't whereas
Ed Miliband never quite seems that
comfortable on the policy level on a
personal level he knows he's weird but
he doesn't embrace his witness he tries
to seem a bit less weird which never
quite works he might as well just be an
alpha now geek because actually then
people would see he was being sincere
how much of this is Miliband how much
this is those around them you know some
have argued that nobody looks good
eating and why they let that happen in
the first place
well people can look goodies in fun I
would disagree with that but the thing
is it's not just a bacon sandwich that
was simply the most comic offer I mean
there is this wonderful moment when he
was you know about to go on the sofa ITV
daybreak and he looks towards the camera
and sort of smiled for a split second
they've been tried this small very sexy
sort of look and it was just hilarious
I was that about 20 times
he has got a knack for being able to
basically entertain you in the way that
it doesn't mean to entertain you so I'm
not quite sure what can be done with it
really except you could try the Gordon
Brown's advisers tried the strategy
initially and I thought it was quite
good they were saying not flash just
Gordon and I thought what kind of you
know works like you can make an
advantage that these no use no arrow to
player is this relatively charmless
scowling Scot and bits I'm not sure Ed
Miliband's advisers can really make a
virtue artifice what's more I don't
really blame them I mean the candidates
there's not much you can really do with
him and so if he can't embrace his
weaknesses Isabel puts it I don't think
he's got as advisers can persuade the
public to embrace that eNOS